and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber after calling just
one witness and questioning him for less
than an hour rapper ynw melly's defense
team has officially rested their case
and that means that this trial is
nearing its close after the state rested
on Monday the defense called its sole
witness Tuesday Morning Adrian Davis
says he was with ynw Melly whose real
name is Jamel demons on the night of the
murders and they happen now that was
back in October of 2018 a group of
friends were leaving a recording studio
late at night in two cars demons got
into a dark colored Jeep with Cortland
Henry Christopher Thomas and Anthony
Williams and another group of young men
got into a red Mitsubishi at some point
Davis testified that the cars pulled
over and demons moved from the Jeep to
the Mitsubishi and they continued to
Demon's home now Davis testified that
they all went to sleep in different
rooms and then woke up to the news that
Williams and Thomas had been shot and
killed Henry drove the two victims to
the hospital telling police that there
had been a drive-by shooting but
investing alligators say they determined
the shots came from inside the car the
prosecution contends that demons was
sitting in the back seat when he shot
the victims both demons and Henry were
charged with murder and they're being
tried separately demons faces the death
penalty if he's convicted now the only
witness the defense called on Tuesday
Adrian Davis testified that Not only was
demons in the Mitsubishi with him but he
was at the house when word came that two
of his childhood friends were dead
did there come a time in the early
morning hours
that you were woken up
and heard some distressing news on the
news
what did you hear the second Julie was
shot
when you heard that
did you see Melly in the house he goes
did you see Melly how he was dressed in
the house yes what was he wearing uh
shorts and a t-shirt
okay
upon hearing that that sacked and
confusing
and I really should use the dark news
Anthony Williams and Christopher Thomas
were shot what what did you guys do
for
we well we were already dressed and
stove so we just left for the Alfredo's
house
did was anybody
upset or crying yeah we all occurred
sure
that Mr Dennis found out at the same
time
no questions about that there are sure
he was at that house yes and you were
upstairs yesterday he was downstairs yes
but you're sure he was there you can see
is that a yes yes
and since the defense already rested
this case will soon be in the hands of
the jury correspondent Terry Austin
breaks down what's next
the judge decided this morning that the
court will be dark on Wednesday and that
is because prosecutor Christine Bradley
is not going to be available she has to
be in court with judge fine to take care
of another matter Court will resume
again on Thursday on Thursday morning
the jury is going to hear the closing
arguments by both the prosecution and
the defense and they will also hear the
jury instructions
the judge has already determined that
once the jury begins to deliberate they
will be sequestered and what that means
is they will not be allowed to go home
in the evenings once they begin their
deliberations they will come to the
courthouse every single day and
deliberate and then go back to the hotel
and spend the night and come back in the
morning that is what the judge has
decided to do this is a double murder
case and they will be sequestered while
they are deliberating
this is Terry Austin recording from the
Broward County Courthouse
all right I'm joined by my co-host
defense attorney Brian buckmeyer and
today's special guest defense attorney
Jeff wolf great to have you both here
Jeff we'll start with you it's all about
Davis's testimony I mean they called him
Soul witness the question is was he
believable what do you think
yeah I think that his demeanor was great
on the stand I don't think he got overly
emotional I don't think he got combative
with a very combative district attorney
which is always helpful I think the
biggest issue that they're going to have
is what's his motive to lie right that's
any eyewitness that you have what is
their motive to lie why should the jury
believe them over the science they heard
for weeks prior and I think that's going
to be the larger issue his friendship
with Melly and how can the prosecution
frame that as the reason that he would
have to come in and lie to the jury but
as far as how he testified his demeanor
the way that he held up on her cross I
think he did a great job I got to tell
you Brian I was surprised I thought they
were going to call I don't know a cell
phone data expert a crime scene
Reconstructionist some other expert but
they didn't they just called one witness
why did they do that yeah I'm surprised
as well but when they did it I started
to make a lot it started to make a lot
of sense to me and ultimately if and I
think Jeff touched on a lot of important
points but if Davis is found incredible
I think at the end of the day the
defense will be playing chess while the
prosecution is playing checkers because
the prosecution is trying to win all of
these battles the cell phone information
the trajectory of the bullets even
potentially a motive but the the defense
is coming in and just simply saying he
wasn't in the car yeah you could say
anything you want about bullets and this
and that and when he got into the car we
have a witness that if you believe him
he wasn't in the car and that's chess
not Checkers it wins every day and
clearly they they're banking on that
testimony because you would think maybe
they would cover their bases a little
bit and say okay even if you don't
believe him maybe we can show you why
the the cell phone the cell phone data
is inaccurate why the crime scene
construction data is inaccurate they're
banking it all on him and a lack of what
the prosecution had and still ahead on
Long crime daily a Milwaukee mother is
arrested on child neglect charges after
her two sons were spotted running naked
in the street the police found in the
family's house of horrors
and welcome back everybody several
Wisconsin residents called 9-1-1 last
week after spotting two young boys naked
in the street covered in marks and
bruises prosecutors are calling this
case quote something out of a horror
movie a criminal complaint states that
police can respond to a Milwaukee home
where neighbors reported a woman yanking
one of the injured boys back into the
home as one officer approached the home
they reported hearing a quieted cry or
whimper and spotted a woman exiting
through a side door that woman was 34
year old Katie Koch the two boys mother
she said the cuts on her kids bodies
were from escaping the home through a
broken window but the responding
officers didn't believe their injuries
were from glass as the officers entered
the home a latch was found on the kid's
bedroom to lock it from the outside
along with mounds of trash and smeared
feces on the walls
one witness told police that the roaming
children were quote acting like cavemen
like they had never seen Sun before Koch
along with her boyfriend Joel manke were
rested on four counts each of felony
child neglect Koch also faces additional
misdemeanor charges mankey's cash Bond
was set at 6 500 meantime Koch is being
held on thirty thousand dollars Bond and
a preliminary hearing is set for July
26th
now Brian what is the state of these
children the way they looked acting like
you know caveman what does that tell you
about the prosecution's case that
information is going to give us all the
insight as to the level of neglect
neglect in many States including here
are broadly defined it could be a lack
of nutrients it could be a lack of
Health Care it could be even physically
assaulting them so their arguments or
their potential defense that they
crawled through glass and got cut
obviously that was debunked by the
officers when they first observed that
but the extent of and the length of this
deprivation of sunlight food nutrients
are just base even education could
amount to stronger or even greater uh
felony childhood neglect cases so the
evaluation of these children are going
to be everything yeah absolutely and and
Jeff we talked about this preliminary
hearing that's going to happen in July
what do we expect from that
so the judge is going to determine if
there's probable cause to move forward
unless the defense waves it to keep
negotiations open with the prosecution
which in a case like this there may not
be negotiations when you have kids in
that state and that abused and that
neglected I don't know that there's
going to be any negotiation so likely a
hearing on the probable cause and Brian
that's pretty easy to move forward the
bar is kind of low even if the defense
doesn't waive it yeah preponderance of
the evidence or will we say more likely
than not or just 51 percent chance if
they can reach that Mark then they've
met their burden and they move on
towards trial you know I'd say it's a
horrifying case and it is but
unfortunately I've heard these things
before way too often it's just a really
sad State of Affairs and we're going to
continue to monitor it and see what
happens at this preliminary hearing